energy of the year and then top selling
album top selling single
how are you going to celebrate tonight
uh i'm going to go to bed early i think
i'm going to i just
well yeah yeah we got some um
we've got some friends coming over we're
gonna watch the uh the broadcast and
and take it easy but uh yeah
yeah i mean entertainer of the year that
it must feel very
different this year to be awarded that
like how does it feel to get that award
this year
yeah it felt like we haven't entertained
in a while that's the thing
i guess if it's a reflection of last
year and we were um
yeah i mean dean and i did that
cross-country friends don't let friends
tour alone tour
um we had lots of festivals um
yeah looking back it was it was a great
year uh connecting with the fans and
and um yeah just enjoying live music
together so
yeah hopefully we can have um an
entertainer of the year
next year and uh we actually have shows
to base it upon
right right and the other two awards i
find that so interesting like
to know in these times where you know
times are tough for people
like in terms of they you know they're
not making the money that they were but
the fact that people are still
spending money on your music like does
that have weight
uh for you yeah yeah it's it's
i mean for me it's not about it's not
about the money it's about the time
spent right i mean everybody's got the
on-demand stuff right they're investing
time and
and it's it's more about you know when
they're
feeling something and they're looking
for something in the music or connected
with us somehow
um them thinking of my music is
pretty humbling man it's pretty i mean i
remember and still in life when i'm in
certain moods or
or need to vent or you know feeling a
certain emotion i go to certain go-to
songs and go to artists so
for me to be um that to somebody else's
i mean that's
that's what this is all about right yeah
yeah i mean i saw you up at burroughs
creek when
we were shooting some of the csmas what
was that experience like for you
obviously a very different
ccmas experience but yeah what was that
like
it was it was different it felt like uh
the easiest the easiest video shoot
i've ever done in my entire life it was
also it was also the strangest um
but yeah everybody wearing masks and
stuff but once we got going and and um
music started playing and the band was
in there we
felt at home yeah one of the things i
really noticed about the ccmas that i
loved so much about the actual show
was how diverse it was do you see that
happening more in country music hell
yeah
absolutely it's happening in every every
way um sonically
the imagery um the inclusivity of who
we're seeing
um in country music and yeah in every
every single way
um and i think that's gonna keep going
and keep creating new just great music
and stuff that we've um
we can't even imagine the different
mixes of music no yeah it sounds and i
love that
you're doing um shows with one of my new
favorite people is jojo mason
what's it been like uh doing some shows
with jojo
yeah jojo he's a friend of mine actually
um we've we kind of grew up in the lower
mainland uh he's a bit younger than i am
but
we share a lot of uh similarities uh
he's just a
it's hard just not to smile around that
guy huge personality
um he's put a lot of work like into
himself into his voice and he's
he's um i think he's onto something he's
got a big boy voice and i think he's on
to great things
yeah what's it been like doing these
shows that are kind of like socially
distant
weird circumstances sets up of shows
uh it's it's it's a bit of a mind f
you know i i like i like uh yeah i i
like
i like the festivals or like the
intimate crowds where it's just like
everybody's right
at the stage and interact and you can
basically all
is sweating on each other but obvious
reasons we can't be doing that right now
so it was
it was good it was great to see like we
just said that we played one last night
in calgary but just the third show in a
row
the song started settling in you know
looking at the guys and feeding off each
other a little bit again and
you know it you take what you can out of
it i mean seeing those faces people
singing the songs from the distant was
great
um so we took what we could out of it
and had fun with it but we're looking
forward to uh
to get back to normal
hey i'm graham o'neill for more on your
favorite country stars click subscribe
or watch the videos
over there